nein städtchen hey ich habe gestern auf
twitter gepostet liege im krankenhaus
berichtet euch die tage was passiert ist
brauche erst ruhe schönen sonntag noch
daraufhin haben so viele leute etwas
darunter geschrieben und gefragt was los
ist und skv volk viele aktionen von euch
der community von wegen dieser ganzen
hashtags mit gute besserung lugano 10
rapid wie das war als mega süß von euch
wie geht's jetzt schon ein bisschen
besser ich bin wieder zu hause und
wollte euch einfach ganz kurz wirklich
noch sagen was passiert ist weil ich
eigentlich gerade dort sein sollte
so sollte ich eigentlich den ganzen tag
liegen also was ist eigentlich passiert
ich bin am samstag haben von köln ihr
nach hause zu meiner familie gefahren
weil ich halt das wochenende hier
verbringen wollte war dann am sonntag
noch bei einem chinesen was essen und
abends noch bei einer freundin den wald
halten ca gegen 12 wieder hier zu hause
war barth und lag dann im bett um 1 und
hat dann halt gemerkt so jo ich muss
glaube ich irgendwie doch scheiße mit
auch zuletzt gegangen und hatte so den
übelsten durchfall wahrheit nicht so
cool habt ihr dabei halt dann erstmal
nicht so gedacht bin halt wieder ins
bett gegangen und bin dann glaub ich zu
gegen zwei eingeschlafen und dann
allerdings wieder um 6 uhr aufgewacht
und ich bin nicht um 6 uhr aufgewacht
weil ich mir ging wie oft einen wecker
gestellt habe sondern weil es mir
einfach mega chance gegen immer wieder
auftritte gegangen hatte wieder
durchfall und hab danach halten noch
wasser getrunken und danach wieder penan
gelegt bis 9 glaube ich am liebsten ich
noch weiter gependelt neustadt haben
motor den ganzen tag termine und musste
morgens zum reifenwechsel und hatte noch
einen anderen arzt termin und deswegen
konnte ich leider nicht noch länger
kennen mir ging es auf jeden fall den
kompletten montag echt scheiße ich stand
auch voll neben der spur also ich konnte
ich richtig denken und deswegen habe ich
halt an dem tag auch kein video
hochgeladen ich lag dann halten ca ab
zwei wieder im bett nach
meisten termine eigentlich fertig hat
und die meisten telefonate geführt habe
und dann hab ich von 4 bis 5 30 ca
geschlafen ich war auf jeden fall übel
ko und hätte auch länger schlafen können
als ich sag mal nur anderthalb stunden
aber ich bin halt aufgewacht und lag
dann halt in meinem bett und hab halt so
gemerkt wie irgendwas ist in meinem
magen losen man wacht dann ja also
gerade auf und daneben habe ich also
alles mal mehr wagen und mein magen die
ganze zeit habe ich dann auf jeden fall
von der waagerechten relativ ruckartige
die weg rechts bewegt war ich halt
dachte dass ich kotzen muss weil ein
magen so komisch gebloggt hat die ganze
zeit und dabei ist enorm viel wasser in
meinem magen noch in der waagerechten in
die senkrechte und ist so richtig so
oben geschraubt wie sonnen wassereimer
ihr kennt das bestimmt wenn ihr zu viel
wasser trinkt und dann sitzt ihr dann
stellt ihr euch hin oder her wackelt mit
eurem bauch da merkt man wie das wasser
haltemarken wie ist aber das waren das
was so viel wasser dass ich hab' ich hab
gedacht ich fahr wiederum zu anderen
seite erinnern auf jeden fall direkt zur
toilette gesprintet und ich also das
hört sich jetzt echt ekelhaft an aber
ich habe einfach viel liter wasser
geschissen bruder stark ich sag's dann
auf jeden fall so um halb sechs danach
dem ich aufgewacht bin auf der toilette
für 10 15 minuten und hatte wenig ganze
kampf nur wasser aus meinem dieser
erzähle ich euch das war auch mal zu mal
kurz beim koleos ministerrat übel war
mir als ich dann jedenfalls auf der
toilette saß und das ganze wasser halt
verloren habe bin ich auch richtig den
vibriert also ich hab wirklich gemerkt
wie meine haut irgendwie trockener wurde
und wie ich immer schlapper wurde und
irgendwie bei mehr nach vorne rüber
gefallen bin mein handy lag halt in der
anderen ecke vom bad und deswegen bin
ich dann zwischenzeitlich kurz
aufgestanden hatte holte mir dann auf
dem pc handy auch so voll rum getorkelt
weil ich halt einfach häufig flüssigkeit
verloren habe und ich hatte halt noch
nie so eine situation dass ich wirklich
so richtig benebelt waren genauso wie
der fokus jetzt gerade beispielsweise
sorry aber ich habe mich den ganzen tag
ausgeruht deswegen wird schon langsam
dunkel draußen und dann funktioniert der
fokus von der kamera nie so gut
jedenfalls hat mein körper dann
enorm viel adrenalin ausgeschüttet und
ich hatte extremist herzrasen und ich
habe wirklich überall in meinem körper
mega geschwitzt und mir stand wirklich
das wasser also das war nicht so
normales schwitzt muss man ihn wieder am
sport hat sondern hier statt wirklich
überall wassermann in meinem gesicht
überall meine mutter hat dann halt
irgendwie mitbekommen dass ich irgendwie
im bad ein bisschen rum torkel und so
und ist ein rein gekommen eine dann
locker geht es sehr gut ich konnte wohl
gar nicht richtig antworten der dann
gesagt der kommt an ist ins krankenhaus
notaufnahme winterhalter hingefahren da
musste ich im krankenhaus noch irgendwie
eine dreiviertelstunde warten bis ich
dran gekommen bin und danach wurde ich
halte die zum zimmer gebracht wo dann
irgend so eine ärztin mir direkt blut
abgenommen hat und dann direkte
infusionen die gleiche kerbe gehauen hat
nur zur info wie ich aussah als wir
angekommen waren im krankenhaus und zwar
so also ich hab das nicht gespielt ich
habe einfach nur warte hat noch mal auf
toilette hat im krankenhaus noch mal
durchfall und habe dann einfach mal mein
handy genommen habe abfolge auf dem weg
hinaus als ich dann komplett neben der
spur überspringt vielleicht die nächsten
15 sekunden wenn ihr nicht sehen können
wie nadeln unter die haut kommen aber
das hier haben die dann bei mir die haut
gerannt und ihr seht auch die haben ein
paar mal vielleicht nicht getroffen weil
da war alles voller blut jedenfalls lag
ich dann so im krankenhaus hat einen
halben liter infusionen direkt in meine
blutbahnen gepusht bekommen ich bin ein
mensch der es überhaupt nicht gerne hart
wenn irgendwie der sprit sind meine
adern kommt also ich kann da eigentlich
nahezu immer um muss mich dabei halt
immer hinlegen und die hat dann das
erste mal seit dem blut abgenommen habe
ich diese infusion bekommen
in der nachhaltigen wie für 20 minuten
eingeplant so zur info sonne infusionen
dauert immer so circa eine stunde das
heißt man hängt da wirklich eine stunde
an diesem gerät und bekommt einfach
dauerhaft irgendwas in den körper
reingepumpt jedenfalls bin ich ein
relativ schnell anhalt eingepennt und
nachdem ich wieder aufgewacht war hat
meine mutter
dann gefilmt wie ich so drauf war hast
du gemacht was passiert erzählen wohnort
ist die toilette als lob sprechen
okay man sieht ich stehe nur leicht
neben der spitze was es mit dem wetter
los ich will das video gar nicht so
lange halten jedenfalls hat meine mutter
dann halt noch mal richtig luca aussage
getroffen hast du noch was zu sagen denn
der akku ist voll gesperrt hast du was
zu sagen alles klar war wissen wir dass
ein akku voll ist jedenfalls durfte ich
dann nach drei vier stunden wieder nach
hause habe ich dann zu hause ins bett
gelegt und seitdem geht es mir
eigentlich echt wieder super als die
ärzte im krankenhaus hat mir dann auch
irgendwie so zwei verschiedene relativ
aggressive wie heißen die diese
tabletten ich habe jetzt mal einfach das
licht hier meine zu machen gemacht das
ist zwar mega beschützen und videos
aufzunehmen aber für die letzten worte
soll es glaube ich reichen und ist auf
jeden fall besser als die beleuchtung
von draußen gerade jedenfalls meistern
so gegen halb elf ca wieder hier in
meinem eigenen bett drin und seitdem
geht es mir echt super also ich man
sollte jetzt am besten dreimal kurz
dreimal auf holz damit aberglaube und so
mir geht zumindest schon mal so gut
wieder dass ich hier stehen kann und
nicht irgendwie umfallen so weit bevor
natürlich liegen auch leute im
krankenhaus die sich gegen wie
was ich meinen gebrochen haben und
nebenbei weil sie nicht in schwierige
hirnerschütterung haben also das was ich
hatte echt nichts krasses aber in dem
moment wo ich auch verletzte saß und
vier liter flüssigkeit verloren habe
hatte ich einfach echt übel das
herzrasen mega adrenalin mega gezittert
bin halb umgefallen haben nachher noch
diese infusion bekommen bin
eingeschlafen stand würde ich neben der
spur und deswegen weiß ich einfach auch
so viele leute gefragt haben dass
wahllos deswegen lag im krankenhaus ich
wollte ich das einfach nur mitteilen
ich hab das gestern haben schon auf
snapshot gemacht aber bei diesem kurzen
10 sekunden steps and videos kann man
natürlich immer die so viel erzählen
hallo ich lieg schon wieder hat es
solche auge gerade gerieben und ist
total roth alter ich habe gerade das
video hier geschnitten und mir ist
aufgefallen ich hab euch jetzt überhaupt
nicht gesagt was ich überhaupt habe
beziehungsweise hatte also als ich in
der sonntag nach den durchfall hatte und
am montag dann meinem namen gesprochen
habe meinte sie halt und auch als in der
apotheke wann man die apothekerin das
ist einfach ganz normaler magen darm
virus sei und der nach drei bis vier
tagen wieder weg sein weil ich hatte ja
relativ leichte anzeichen dass ich hatte
eher ich sag mal nur durchfall und
übelkeit so ein bisschen ich hab es aber
nicht wirklich gebrochen oder hatte so
übels das herzrasen oder schwindel zu
dem zeitpunkt weiß ich dass wir doch den
tag danach
das hatte was ich euch erzählt habe
gerade in dem video also das mit dem
dass ich wirklich übel viel flüssigkeit
in form von durchfall verloren habe
da wurden die amtszeit bis zum ende
symptome halt immer krasser und als ich
das dann der doktoren im krankenhaus
erzählt habe meinte sie halt dass das
auch der norovirus sein könnte sie sich
aber nicht ganz sicher sei weil ich kein
mal gebrochen habe und der logo virus
ist eigentlich so dass man wirklich
gefühlt
15 und 20 minuten irgendwie auf toilette
rennt und trotzdem dann auch in
verbindung mit mit durchfall und so das
hatte ich halt nicht also ich hatte
wirklich nur den durchfall und halt ein
bisschen übelkeit und so was alles also
hat die tante dann im krankenhaus
einfach gesagt so jo das ist
wahrscheinlich entweder eine
lebensmittelunverträglichkeit in
kombination mit einer magen-darm-grippe
rinnen markt darm grippe ist es auf
jeden fall und zwar eine sehr aggressive
gewesen und wie ich jetzt quasi weiter
vorgehe ist dass ich mich halt gerade
schone soll im bett und macht das auch
morgen wahrscheinlich noch den ganzen
tag und stress jetzt halt gerade nur
gekochte kartoffeln und trinkt tee und
zwieback und so und ich werde halt in
drei wochen zu meinem hausarzt gehen das
hat mir die ärztin hat muss auch werk
und mal so einen test durchführen ob ich
irgendwas sagen ich meinen allergisch
bin also ob ich irgendwie gegen
blutarmut oder ob ich eine fruktose oder
laktose intoleranz habe einfach damit
man halt mal schaut wo das ganze heer
kam und es quasi demnächst wieder
vermeiden kann weil das halt schon krass
war mein auge ist so roth nur weil dies
gerade die jugend alter her was ist
damit schon wieder los luca macht jetzt
auf jeden fall die ent card und das
video hat jetzt halt eigentlich gar kein
dinner geben habe ich mir gerade im
schnitt gedacht weil ich überhaupt nicht
gesagt was jetzt überhaupt diagnose war
was ich genau habe aber mir geht's auf
jeden fall schon besser
und ja ich hoffe dass ich morgen wieder
normales anderes video hochladen kann
ich werde mich jetzt auf jeden fall den
kompletten abend wieder ins bett begeben
dieses videos schneiden und dann wie
hoch waren begeistert des wdr 4 dead or
alive and education disney dann könnt
ihr main kanal abonnieren wenn ihr auf
das bild darauf klickt und ihr seht hier
das video von vorgestern eingeblendet
hab ich nämlich die teuersten
gegenstände der welt vorgestellt
auch ein sehr cooles video geworden
sollte auf jeden fall mal abchecken und
danke für eure ganzen genesungswünsche
war sehr lieb und sieht von euch